Hello, I am Ron Vale.
Today I have the great
pleasure to be speaking with
Jim Rothman and Randy Schekman,
who just returned
to the United States from Stockholm
where they received the 2013
Nobel Prize in Physiology or Medicine
along with their colleague Tom Sudhof.
This trio was awarded the prize
for their seminal work in uncovering
the molecular machinery that is involved
in membrane trafficking
and protein or neurotransmitter secretion.
This is a journey of proteins
through a cell
that starts with protein insertion
into the endoplasmic reticulum.
Those proteins are then recognized
as cargo, packaged,
and then transported
as small vesicles
to the next way station,
which is the Golgi apparatus.
And from there
they are transported to new
membrane destinations,
such as the lysosome,
or the plasma membrane.
And this trio of Sudhof, Rothman, and
Schekman found the
molecular machinery
that is involved in each step
of this pathway through the cell.
So thank you for joining us today.
And I'd like to begin
with the science.
And maybe, Randy, I could ask you
if you could describe the work
that Jim did that led to his
contributions for the Nobel Prize.
Schekman: I am happy to do that.
I first met Jim when he interviewed
for a faculty position at Berkeley.
As an assistant professor I had been there
about a year.
And he told me in broad
terms about his plan,
which I certainly
appreciated being a biochemist.
And then he went and did it at Stanford.
Very quickly, he launched
into developing a cell-free reaction
to reproduce traffic, at least initially,
he thought it was traffic
from the ER to the Golgi.
Subsequently he turned out to be
measuring traffic,
vesicular traffic, within the Golgi.
And he used that to identify
soluble proteins
that he called NSF, for N-ethylmaleimide
sensitive protein
and its SNAP, which
was its membrane receptor for NSF,
and showed that these
were involved at some point
in membrane fusion.
And then in a really brilliant experiment,
several years later,
he used the
NSF and alpha-SNAP complex,
bound by non-hydrolyzable ATP analog,
to fish out of membranes
from a crude detergent soluble fraction
from bovine brain
the proteins that turned out
to be the membrane anchors
and the catalysts for fusion,
which he called SNARE proteins.
So it was a really beautiful synthesis
of the biochemistry
and functional analysis.
Vale: And Jim maybe
I could ask you the same question.
Could you comment
on the key discoveries and contributions
that Randy made
that led to his
being awarded the Nobel Prize?
Rothman: This is a great pleasure
to have a chance to.
Randy and I have been joking
for a long time
about giving each other's seminars,
so you've given us
a great chance to do that, Ron.
Randy in the... starting in the late 1970s,
took on a problem
that was extremely adventurous.
And people at that time,
model organisms were not
what they are today.
There were very few examples
where for example yeast had been used
to really forge ahead and understand
complex eukaryotic pathways.
As Randy points out,
the yeast cell cycle was one.
People doubted actually
that there was a secretory pathway in yeast
that reflected in any meaningful way
the similarity to the Palade pathway
that we all had understood at the time.
The Golgi apparatus, if it was observed,
it was only scantily observed.
And Randy especially
in a really innovative approach
was able to isolate a series of mutations.
First based on kind of brute screening,
and then after that based on a
really important experimental insight
about if you have a cell
that is making protein
but not excreting the protein
it's going to get denser.
So based on that
Randy was able to isolate
a large number of mutations
systematically that essentially defined
the entire secretory pathway
and the major secretory organelles in yeast.
And established the generality
of the pathway. But more importantly
they provided the means to discover
the molecular machinery
that is important in various stages
of vesicle budding and fusion.
And it's turned out
that over the years that
the genes that Randy
initially discovered,
23 of them,
play pivotal roles in multiple stages
of the secretory pathway.
Some at all stages of vesicular trafficking.
His students and others
have followed in his footsteps
and have essentially
laid out the entire map
of the transport pathways
in the yeast cell.
Vale: So both of you
shared some interesting similarities
in terms of how your careers started.
You're both trained as
biochemists in some great laboratories.
And you then became assistant professors
both at a very young age.
And then both of you picked
very risky problems to start your laboratories.
So I'd like to get some background
of how you came up
with this project,
and how you decided to tackle it.
So maybe I could start with you Randy?
Maybe you can just tell me how you ended up
choosing the problem membrane secretion
and also taking a genetic approach.
Schekman: Near the end of my graduate career,
in looking at the literature on membranes,
largely influenced by Bill Wickner
who was a postdoc in Arthur's lab
at the time who also had come from Kennedy's lab
that biological membranes were likely to be
a subject that one could
learn a great deal about biosynthesis.
One could possibly treat
a biological membrane
as a macromolecule
and dissect its biogenesis
using the techniques of
biochemistry and genetics
in a way that hadn't really
been applied yet.
So I went to John Singer's lab
to learn about what he was thinking
about biological membranes
and I found myself on a project
that didn't really have a future in my mind.
It was using a scarce material,
and I found that
working with mammalian cells,
at least at that time
in the mid 1970s
was not as satisfying as working with a microorganism.
So I resolved when I joined
the faculty at Berkeley
influenced to some extent,
some large extent
by the success of Lee Hartwell
in his genetic dissection
of the cell division cycle
that I would then
launch an independent career using
some kind of genetic analysis
of membrane biogenesis.
And Peter Novick
was one of my first graduate students
and it was my good fortune that he joined my lab.
He was a very thoughtful, very precise,
hardworking, really brilliant student.
And so we, the two of us,
sort of embarked on this
effort to identify
the genes involved in secretion
by a genetic approach.
It was kind of a trial and error.
Initially we had some crazy idea
about the need for a genetic selection
that didn't work.
We found a mutant in spite
of it being a selection that didn't work
we found the first mutant anyways,
and we realized that it was a complex pathway
and that probably just looking
through a random assortment
of temperature sensitive mutants,
just as Hartwell had done,
would turn up more genes.
And we did find another one,
but as Jim mentioned earlier,
we decided to use an enrichment procedure
and isolated a lot more mutations.
So it was a good choice obviously.
It worked out well.
It's not the traditional way that
one starts a career.
Usually postdocs are
a little more conservative
but I always advise my postdocs
to be more bold
and to do something new.
But of course when you do something
new there's a good chance you will fail.
So what I did was I started
several different projects.
This one worked within a year.
And then I marshaled
all of my efforts to focus on that.
Vale: So as a follow up, I was wondering
if you could explain the assay that you used
to get the second mutant.
And also your reaction
to that amazing electron micrograph
in the Figure 6 of your 1979 paper
that shows this yeast cell
filled with all of these vesicles
that could no longer reach the cell surface.
Schekman: So the idea was that in looking at
thin sections in yeast cells
one can see some organelles
that look like they could be associated
with secretion.
Not as dramatic as in a section
of mammalian cells, but Novick and I guessed
that the vesicles that one sees
congregating under the bud portion of a dividing cell
would be the vehicle not only for secretion,
but for assembly of the plasma membrane.
And so we predicted
that anything that blocked
the biogenesis of these vesicles
would be lethal
and that therefore that one would have
to go after conditional,
temperature sensitive
lethal mutations.
So that was our first and crucial assumption
that it was going to be an essential gene.
And the second was that
the mutant would,
at a restrictive temperature,
cause secretory proteins,
which are otherwise very efficiently
secreted from the cell,
to accumulate inside the cell.
And that actually was a really trivial assay.
You just assay intact cells,
which measures the enzyme
that has been trapped in the cell walls.
The cell wall is porous.
And then you dissolve the cell wall
with an enzyme,
and you have spheroblasts left.
And then you just rupture
the spheroblasts with detergent
and you assay what is
inside the spheroblast,
and that is a measure of
the accumulation.
In a wildtype cell,
that baseline is virtually zero.
In a sec mutant it rises dramatically
above the background.
So the first mutant,
just based on a biochemical
enzyme assay was really obviously
blocked in multiple
secretory enzyme transport.
But the dramatic result came
just around the time
that George Palade visited Berkeley
for a special lecture
and I recall Novick telling me
at the luncheon that
Palade had encouraged him
with these preliminary results
to cut a thin section
and look and see what these cells looked like.
And so we got an expert technical assistant
in the department,
and that of course was one of the
great eureka moments of my career
when Novick excitedly
called me down to the EM room
and showed me these
sec1 cell sections
that were like they had measles.
They were just full of vesicles
and nothing like that
had ever been published.
I don't think it had ever been
seen before.
And from that moment,
literally from that moment
on, I knew we would have at least
several decades worth of productive work.
Vale: Well Jim, let me ask you
a similar question.
You started off your career at Stanford
as a very young assistant professor
You had experience with the VSV virus from
your previous work,
but you decided to tackle
a very difficult problem,
which was to try to reconstitute
parts of the protein secretion
pathway in a cell free extract.
And in fact many people
thought that wouldn't work.
And that it would be
an extremely risky project to take
on so I was wondering if you
could give a little bit about
your thinking
and the background that
led to that particular project.
Rothman: My exposure to
this entire area of
biology began as a medical
student in my first year
at Harvard Medical School.
And George Palade's
discoveries were really fresh
and they were presented
in my histology course.
And when I saw those
electron micrographs of vesicles
and endoplasmic reticulum
and Golgi
I immediately started
thinking given my background
in physical sciences,
how in the world can such a vesicle from, you know...
what would make that happen,
and how would it know where to fuse?
And I must say somehow I identified
that problem as one that
I wanted to solve
at some point and I got fixated on it.
And I can't really tell you why,
but I just got fixated on it.
I found it as fascinating then as I do now.
And after leaving medical school
and finishing my PhD with Gene Kennedy,
I did learn some basic biochemistry
of membranes and lipids.
I went to work with Harvey Lodish
for a year or two,
and I did it with the freedom
of having already my assistant professor
offer in hand.
So I was able to do pretty much what
I wanted and focus
on really educating myself.
And from Harvey and his colleagues
I learned how to work with
complex cell free systems
where we were using cell free extracts
that were synthesizing protein.
We learned following the footsteps
of Gunter Blobel how to
study the incorporation of those proteins
in vitro into the endoplasmic reticulum
membrane and that
really equipped me very well.
Now when I went to Stanford
in 1978, like Randy
I pursued several different projects.
And that was a way of distributing the risk,
but then again I made a
decision to focus intensively
on one project when
we did have some success
after some period of time,
and that is the project
you're referring to
the reconstitution of
transport in a cell free extract.
And I think that decision
that Randy made
and the decision that I made
is a very important
decision that young scientists
can make which is
that at some point you really have to focus.
And you have to focus deeply on something.
And in the long run if you want to make
a contribution that is really worth making
rather than simply incremental,
you have to stick
as Randy did and
frankly as you did Ron
to that decision.
It's not always going to be easy.
And it's certainly not free of risk,
but it has great rewards
for science when you are successful.
So what we did was we
wanted to reconstitute transport
from the ER to the Golgi
so we took the cells,
living, we gave them a
very short pulse label
with radioactive methionine,
and tricks I had learned in Harvey Lodish's lab,
then homogenized
the cells to retain them,
the G protein, in the endoplasmic reticulum.
And then we incubated that extract
to see if the glycoprotein
could be further processed
by adding certain sugar residues,
especially N-acetylglucosamine,
which we knew
from the work of Phil Robbins
and Stuart Kornfeld
and others occurred in the Golgi.
And we could see that processing in vitro,
it would have suggested
the transport occurred.
And indeed, after I don't know,
a month or two,
we observed
that that was the case.
We could see it.
But we had a huge background.
Even without any kind of incubation
longer than a few seconds,
even without adding ATP or cytosol
we still saw processing and what we
came to realize was that
we already had too much of the G protein
sitting in the Golgi
and it was getting glycosylated
directly there. So that gave me the idea
of what is now known as a complementation assay
which is pretty much
the standard design for most
cell free (in those days)
cell free reconstitution of transport
and the idea is  you want
to mix two extracts,
one from the cell that contains the cargo protein, VSV-G,
but lacks the processing enzyme,
The other extract
from the cell that
lacks the processing enzyme,
but... excuse me.
Has the processing enzyme,
but lacks the cargo protein.
And so when the two are mixed,
if the cargo protein
is getting glycosylated,
it must have gone from
a donor membrane
in the extract of the one cell
to the processing enzyme
in the Golgi
of the other cell.
And so that eliminated the background
that I referred to
because the extract
with the VSV-G protein in it was
incapable of processing by adding sugar.
So when we set that assay
up it actually worked.
It was in I believe 1979.
I still have the gel
that shows a very, very faint band
of the VSV-G protein being
processed to what is called an
endo-H resistant form.
And it was very, very exciting.
Vale: Randy, you were
originally trained as a biochemist
with one of the master
biochemists, Arthur Kornberg.
You then began to
pursue this problem
of membrane secretion in yeast
using a genetic approach.
When did you decide it was the right moment
to start to begin a
biochemical dissection of this problem?
Schekman: Our approach to initiate
with genetics was always, in my mind,
just a stepping-stone into biochemistry.
It as not going to... I didn't want to pursue it
purely by genetic analysis.
I had every intention of using
this to develop some
kind of cell-free reaction.
It was a challenge to get people
in my lab to think that way,
because when something is working
everybody who joins your lab
wants to keep doing that thing.
They wanted to isolate more mutants.
They wanted to clone more genes,
but convincing any of them
to actually take a step back
and do something very different,
which to me would have been
the obvious thing
was tough.
So fortunately after six or seven years,
David Baker joined the lab.
And he was brash
and considered our efforts
in that direction
inefficient and ineffective.
And within two weeks
he had developed a cell free reaction
that reproduced the first half
of the secretory pathway in vitro.
And from that point on,
everyone that joined the lab said okay,
I want to do the biochemistry
because it was obvious
how valuable that would be.
So what's the lesson here?
I guess you have to have
the courage of your own convictions
and be persistent
and I think particularly this kind of
biochemical approach if you had
success in that in the past
you have as an article of faith,
really certainty,
that you can do it again.
And I felt confident that we could
and of course, Jim had succeeded,
so I felt doubly confident
that we could do it.
And that was a plan
right from the start.
Vale: Jim, I know you were originally trained
as a physicist,
then you did beautiful
physical chemistry work,
with Eugene Kennedy,
and eventually
you managed to mature
your research problem
in vesicular trafficking
to the point where you were able to get
purified membranes and purified proteins
SNARE proteins, and reconstitute,
a membrane fusion reaction.
So that must have been a very satisfying
moment and I was wondering if you could explain
how you got to that particular
transition where you could study
this problem in this really well-defined manner.
The history of that work
was we were left logically with NSF, SNAP,
and SNAREs as components of the fusion
machinery.
Bill Wickner did an experiment
in his vacuole fusion system
that established actually that NSF
doesn't participate directly in...
NSF and SNAPs, do not directly participate
in the fusion reaction per se.
When put together with our earlier finding
that the ATP hydrolysis by NSF
disrupts the SNARE complex,
he essentially educated us,
somewhat reluctantly I might add
that NSF must be... while it is critical
to energize the system
is acting either after the fusion reaction
or prior to separating
pre-existing SNARE complexes.
In any case it left the SNAREs
pardon me, as the only
logical candidates. So with that in mind,
I would say we weren't surprised
that the SNARE complex
mediated fusion. And later,
that year Reinhard Jahn
and Axel Brunger had published
the X-ray structure
that showed a hairpin arrangement
and so it all really came together
in that respect in 1998.
And you might say that since then
we've been trying
to study more or less the physical chemistry.
My current focus is
the still unresolved problem of exactly how
calcium, synaptotagmin,
and complexin,
put a brake on fusion
at the last millisecond
in the case of the synapse.
And how they orchestrate
in a highly
amplified and synchronous fashion
the release of the neurotransmitters.
That also is a problem in physical biochemistry,
which I find enormously satisfying.
So it's sort of fun for me
towards the end of a
relatively long career,
it’s been forty years almost
in research since I left university
to come back
and have an opportunity
to really take this problem
to the structural and biochemical level
Vale: So I am curious
when you first became
aware of each other's work
and also while all these
exciting developments were happening
in each of your own labs,
were the two of you in communication
with one another?
Schekman: We were in touch with each other.
I mean after all,
Jim was at Stanford
and I was at Berkeley.
We actually had one or two
day long joint group meetings
Rothman: Two.
Schekman: Was it two?
There was some tension
between us at the time.
I think it was because
you know, we both wanted to make our name
and you know,
it was a new area,
and we were carving out
our own approach, and that was...
Rothman: But we still were very
much in communication.
It was very open.
And I'll tell you something that's a little
different today.
Oftentimes, there were never times,
when you didn't share an idea with me
that you were thinking about.
We weren't doing exactly the same experiments.
And I would always feel comfortable talking to you
about something that I was thinking about,
even before we started the experiment.
Because, you know, there's just
a certain pride of craftsmanship
and respect that really good colleagues
have even if they are
competitive with each other.
I think we always had that.
But there was still some tension.
And I think that dissolved
later on, especially,
when it became clear that we
had identified genes that
were coding proteins
that we could study.
At that point, it actually...
we both felt that we could establish ourselves
at the same time, but
through a different approach.
Vale: So obviously both of you
have had incredibly exciting careers in the field of
membrane trafficking.
If you had a chance to do it all over again,
right now, would this be the scientific
problem that you would pursue?
Schekman: Jim and I have had this conversation,
which is if we were young,
again would we start in this field
all over again? And you know, in 2013.
And the answer for very personal reasons,
is no. I would not.
And I think Jim shares this feeling.
Jim: Yeah, I wouldn't either.
Schekman: Because you know,
it's a relatively mature field.
I think there are many interesting things to discover.
But, you know,
you heard what I said earlier.
I wanted to make my own identity.
I didn't want to be
in someone else's shadow.
And so for that reason,
if I were starting over again
I would pick something brand new
that was underexplored, and where
I'd have a lot of time
and freedom to develop
a novel approach and make new discoveries,
really significant new discoveries.
So I don't mean to discourage
people from thinking that way,
Jim: If I could say at another level,
I totally agree with what you said, Randy.
But it all depends on
your scientific focus.
So if I was a young...
I am a professor of chemistry at Yale.
I am getting a lot of interest
in my work now from the chemists.
You know, because at another level,
this is now a problem
that where the biology is considered
relatively solved.
Nothing is ever completely solved.
Nobel Prizes aren't given out for stuff
that is basically solved.
On the other hand, it's a problem that has just been defined
from the point of view
of the physical biochemistry
and the chemical biology
that can come from it.
So depending on your world view,
for cell biologists or developmental biologists,
there's probably other things to do
that are really bigger challenges today.
For chemists, physical chemists, even physicists,
and people interested in modeling
it's really, really primary.